yeah so thanks everyone for coming it's
great to be here and this is my first
time at the SF data ang meet up so that
sounds good so I'm going to talk today
about the system called Zen that we
built at Pinterest which is our graph
storage service so normally i do this
talk with my colleague shun but
unfortunately couldn't make it today so
i'm going to do this part i'm going to
try to do as best as I can through the
second part of the talk so usually what
I do is I do the the overall sort of
motivation for this project the API and
the high level design and then the
second part of the talk is a little bit
about the internals and learnings from
running this in production over the last
one and half years so that's the part
that should normally does but I'll try
to do my best and feel free to interrupt
with questions at any time it's pretty
informal looks like here so we'll keep
it that way just let me know if you have
any questions at any time so a little
bit of introduction to how we sort of do
engineering at Pinterest so we are
pretty early stage i mean i guess like
not that early stage anymore but being
where we are we like to I trait a lot on
the product like experiment with a lot
of different things see what works see
what doesn't and that means that we need
to be able to I trait quickly and build
products fast so here's an example of a
product that we built last year which is
called messages which basically allows
you to communicate with other users of
Pinterest and send messages to them
about some content that you saw on
pinterest like so if you saw pin that
you like I don't know how many people
use Pinterest assume of many in this
audience good okay it's good nice thanks
so so if you find something that you
like on pinterest and you wanted to sort
of send it to your spouse or a friend
you can with this product do it without
leaving the pinterest experience so it's
a pretty compelling adding product and
with the but the cool thing about it is
it was actually built from scratch to
production full production launch in
three months he has another product
which is news
kind of gives you a sense of what people
are doing on pinterest that you're
connected to on say other social
networks or you're following on
pinterest kind of get a sense of what
they like what boards they've created
what they are pinned recently who they
are following so again like sort of a
pretty compelling product one would
imagine not so trivial to build but this
was actually built in about two months
so this is something that we like a lot
and we want to do consistently so we
asked ourselves like how can we do this
consistently and I think it's a little
bit about culture hiring the people with
that sort of mindset of building things
fast having small teams that can focus
so few things around sort of culture but
to us on the infrastructure team it's
like the the main thing is to build
infrastructure that does not get in the
way because sometimes when you want to
move fast infrastructure can become a
bottleneck and we try really hard to not
make that happen or as often as possible
make sure that that's not the case and
actually like Facebook famously at this
motto it said move fast and break things
I know if you guys noticed but last year
they said actually they think of it now
is move fast with stable infra which
which actually resonates with us as well
right like so sorry yeah so this is
something that we'd like to aspire for
as well like to to be able to move fast
but also do it with some level of
stability and reliability and the way we
have attempted to do that and it's what
pretty well so far i think is to kind of
make it a goal of systems that we build
to this sort of this notion of move fast
to be a goal of system that we build so
when you build a storage system you
obviously worried about reliability
stability durability and so on but you
may not marry so much about sort of like
making it super convenient for product
engineers to move quickly on top of it
but that's something that we think of
sort of a first-class design constraint
when we build systems and we also try to
set up teams that span sort of product
engineers and infrastructure engineers
so
where the infrastructure engines can
focus on the reliability aspect and the
product engineers can focus on my new
user experience so now let's look at how
this approach applies to one aspect of
infrastructure which is persistent
storage obviously there's many things in
infrastructure but I'm going to talk
today about sort of storage so let's
imagine you're trying to build a product
and you are using a distributed database
like we use HBase and some sort of a
sharded MySQL solution at Pinterest and
so these databases come with a lot of
features but they're usually key value
and there's a number of things that you
end up needing to do so you need to
figure out how to model your data on top
of what the database offers many many
cases there's fault tolerance built into
the database but this things that you
need to do on the application side you
need to be able to do capacity
management in sort of a fast growing
environment like a product when it takes
off at Pinterest suddenly scales very
quickly so you need to be able to how a
way to add capacity performance tuning
and things like that so what we sort of
the first solution that we did to take
some of this burden away from art
product engineers was I think what's
sort of pretty common in the industry
which is this notion of storage is a
service so I mean amazon offers some of
this as well on AWS but the idea is
basically to offer a some kind of an api
like we use thrift as a protocol RPC
protocols within Pinterest so the idea
is to rather than deal with the database
directly you deal with an abstraction
layer on top of the database which means
that sort of behind that abstraction
layer we can do a number of things for
you so things like key partitioning to
do effective load balancing we actually
run redundant clusters with some some
level of failover for higher
availability we do speculative execution
to reduce tail Layton sees and we can do
things like multi-tenancy to get you
better efficient efficiency and so on
across different use cases so this was
our first step which was storage as a
service and we found it to be a great
step forward so like our engineers
really liked being able to build on top
of this sort of abstraction layer rather
than dealing with the vagaries of a
database and all that stuff but he asked
her versus like can we do even better
like can we make it even simpler and I
think to illustrate the problem here's
the i just showed the messages product
earlier so if you think of like suppose
you want to build this product at scale
and the data model would look something
like this like you have users that
participate in a conversation and a
conversation contains a sequence of
messages and the kinds of queries you
you would do here is sort of given a
user give me a list of conversations
they're a part of or let's say given a
conversation how many users that are
part of it like a count or maybe you
want a give me the most recent messages
for a conversation so that you can
display it in some part of the site so
if you look at these kinds of queries
building on top of a key value store is
actually non-trivial you have to build a
lot of different tables build indexes do
some work to keep it consistent and so
what we found that is that this is sort
of a repeated pattern and the
realization that we had was really these
object models they resemble a graph more
than sort of key value so and this was
true for a lot of features that we build
at sort of a social site like Pinterest
lot of them are sort of relationships
between users and certain objects on the
side and so we found that if you think
of it as a graph and where these objects
are nodes in that graph and they just
represent relationships between objects
it becomes very natural to express some
of the operation that I just described
as graph queries and these are very very
simple graph queries like given a node
give me some data for that node give me
outgoing edges from that node or
incoming edges or terms of
coming in outgoing edges so so that's
that's basically what design is so Zen
is a storage as a service kind of
abstraction but with a graph data model
instead of a key value data model and
behind the scenes it creates all the
necessary indexes that you need to
support sort of a graph model it
materializes counts separately so that
you can query them efficiently and the
first version of zem has been
implemented on top of HBase but we
intentionally sort of designed it to be
able to plug in other backends as
necessary in fact right now we are
working on a my SQL backend for them so
the idea is that you you work with as
napi behind the scenes will kind of use
HP's or MySQL depending on various needs
depending on your workload and so on and
what works best for us longer term so so
one thing I want to clarify is what Zen
is not it's not a full-fledged sort of
graph database so there are graph
databases out there and so one of the
questions we get is why not use a new 4j
or something like that but so that's not
what Zen is it's not meant for advanced
graph operations like set up for search
random walks or anything like that it's
really sort of a more convenient way of
modeling your data rather than key value
and the key thing is it's built on top
of existing databases so so we know how
to operate HBase and mysql its scale at
very large scale at Pinterest we know
what to do backups durability few lower
availability and so on we love that and
we just like a convenient abstraction on
top of it that product engineers can use
to write code fast so that that's really
what Zen is so with that I will go into
the API but any questions so far that
makes sense yes
yeah so that's a very good question just
pretty much key value so you will see
our data model in a little bit it's a
sort of a distributed key value database
like as long as you have something that
makes that and obviously durability and
things like that but so we have
something like say rocks DB or something
wouldn't work without a lot of work to
add replication and things like that but
any distributed sort of key value
database in theory you can plug in as a
back end to them memcache yes in theory
so if you don't want durability you
could build right on top of memcache as
well yes ki partitioning yes yeah I'll
talk a little bit about the HBase sort
of how we model this data on top of H
makes good so very quickly on the Zen
API it's pretty simple once you sort of
get that sort of graph data model so you
have nodes you can do the basic crud
operations and nodes add/remove get
nodes are referenced by globally unique
64-bit integers called node IDs so these
are generated by Zen whenever you create
a node you'll get a node ID back the
data that you associate with nodes are
in the form of these key value pairs
called properties so they are simply
like sort of string to arbitrary byte
values and I will talk a little bit
later into why we model data this way in
terms of sort of properties and then
there's edges again you can do sort of
basic crud operations on edges you can
also attach property to edges just like
you can attach property two nodes edges
don't have unique IDs they are
referenced by the from node ID the two
node ID and an edge type so they can be
only one edge of a certain type between
a pair of nodes all edges on xen are
directed and you can query them from
both directions so
to that in a second there's also a score
associated with each edge that whenever
you're retrieving a list of edges you
can retrieve them by that score sorted
by that score so that just think of sort
of when you want to get all the messages
for a conversation you might want to
receive get them in reverse
chronological order or something like
that so then you would use score to
order them in that way and then this is
this the multi edge queries so
essentially you specify the query as a
node ID an edge direction like incoming
or outgoing and an edge type once you
have this these three pieces of
information you can do get edge queries
you can do counts you can do remove
edges all of this works the same way and
when you do get edge the edges are
retrieved in score order as I said and
they're also paginate 'add in the sense
that you can sort of do the limit offset
model of retrieving pages pages of edges
up to millions of how many are you want
there's one other feature in them which
should be found to be pretty useful is
this notion of property indexes and this
is why we have the data modeled in the
form of this key value pairs called
properties now what you can do is you
can attach a certain attributes to these
properties so you can say this property
is has a unique index attribute what
that means is that Zen will ensure that
the value of that property is unique
across all nodes or edges of that type
and I will give an example of each of
these couple of slides but and non
unique index is just a way of sort of
retrieving nodes or edges by the value
of a property so give me all nodes which
have property foo equals bar or whatever
right like so you can do things like
that and this works for both nodes and
edges because you can you have data
associated with both nodes and edges so
then is a type system kind of a very
very loose sort of type system so you
don't have to declare yeah so whenever
you add a node or edge to to a Zen
cluster you need to declare the type in
advance you don't need to declare each
and every property so it's free schema
so you can
as many properties as you wish but
obviously you need to tell us which
properties you want unique and non
unique index attributes on so you
specify that through the type schema the
type schema is fully online if there is
no deploy or config it with an API for
it you can add types and actually we
implemented that on top of Zen itself so
it's kind of interesting so hopefully
this will give an idea of how you you'd
how you would use Zen right like so if
you want to build the messages product
that i showed earlier with that data
model what you would do is you would
create three node types so user
conversation and message and to edge
types participate sand contains you
would add some properties to each of
these nodes and that's it like so pretty
much you're done at that point and all
the queries that we talked about earlier
essentially work out of the box the
things like given a user give me the
list of conversations or counts or you
need either direction like all of the
square is that we talked about earlier
just work now there's also an example
here of the unique and non unique index
attributes so let's say I wanted to
ensure that user names are unique across
all nodes of type user all I do is
attach the unique index attribute to the
name property and then we'll ensure that
and let's say I want to like this
conversation the relay about pins on
pinterest so there's a pin ID property
with each conversation now let's say I
want to do a queries which says given up
in ID 10001 give me all the
conversations that are about that pin so
like when you we will fill in pinterest
you might want to show what people are
talking about it so all you do is you
attach this non unique index attribute
to that pin ID property and you can do
that query and you basically are able to
retrieve all the conversations again in
a paginate at varian everything so so
that's sort of the basic data model of
Zen and so we built this in fall of 2013
roughly about one and half years back
and so since then actually it's worked
out pretty well and almost every large
product feature in Pinterest that's been
launched since then has used then in
some fashion so for example smart feed
which is a current version of our home
feed system messages which I talked
about Network meals or interest graph is
modeled on top of Zen several other
upcoming features are built on this so
the number is given here a little bit
dated but yeah so we have about 10
clusters doing an aggregate hundreds of
thousands of requests per second many of
these are large batch requests like you
to retrieve edges in batches or you add
edges in batches so terms of HBase
operations it comes to over five million
every second so it's only get pretty
large scale at Pinterest it's worked
well pretty well for us so so after the
seven yes I session there I'm going to
be what you're showing so I'm going to
talk a little bit about the internals
and learnings from running this in
production now before I get into that
any question any other questions so far
about the API or okay yeah so the
question was how big is the how big are
these clusters so that's a good question
they vary quite a bit in size some are I
think 15 on some are 200 nodes 300 nods
and by nodes I mean ec2 instances yeah
so it depends on the use case we have
kind of a a main cluster that's
multi-tenant so when new users come in
we kind of onboard them onto the main
cluster but when there are really large
use cases we separate them out or
something that needs real heavy
isolation or I'm going to talk about
some storage system level tuning that we
are done in for some specific use cases
so when we need to do that we isolate
them into different clusters yeah
yeah sure but that's actually a good
question so the question is how big are
the keys and values so the keys are sort
of within our control and I will talk
about in the data model i'm going to
show what the keys are so they're
usually relatively small the values can
be arbitrary large and that actually I
think the question on about using
different backends yes so I think when
you use a certain back end they might be
constraints so for example as we are
building the my SQL backend a free
completely free schema is no longer
possible like you need to in some sense
define your properties in advance with
HBase we have the ability to like
whatever add whatever properties you
want so yes I suspect that that will be
sort of an issue is like depending on
which back-end you use there are certain
limitations that you might run into but
with HBase in terms of values we there's
no real limitation you can be pretty
large
yes yes good point yeah how do you test
the load you mean for the same system or
oh how do I get that number there or oh
we have a lot of metrics so we have a
sort of a matrix collection system at
Pinterest and all of our services export
matrix and sort of oh and yeah so our
matrix collection system so we have
dashboards and so on which show how much
QPS we're doing at any instant of time
when you're considering the system it
sounds like you guys took a heavy
account well we could introduce new
yeah but we don't operate yes boy so
instead of of our house yeah how early
in the growing process like start
thinking about that like what kind of
like things when it I have 120 it's
obviously our big well I mean now the
point mechanism even better slaughtering
submission for him too yep Stickney over
get in that and basically portion
yeah but I just come to trade off
somehow you ended up
sure yeah so the question is how did we
sort of come up with addition of
potentially introducing a new database
and taking some of the operational work
to get that database in production
versus building on top of database that
we know and doing all the work to do a
graph data model on top of it that's a
very good question so I think there's a
few answers to that so one is neo4j
strikes me as I have not used it very
closely but it strikes me as sort of
meant to do graph operations themselves
right like things like I actually have a
large graph of like page rank or some
kind of a graph computation so our use
case is really not that way so they were
just product features that were being
built and needed to work at very very
high large scale at very high throughput
very low latency and I you online user
facing way and not sort of offline
computations but we found sort of
modeling your data thinking of your data
in the form of a graph was useful and so
if you take something like neo4j and put
it in the scale that we are talking
about i think it would have been a bit
of a challenge to sort of work at that
scale and for that type of online user
facing use case where Layton sees are
important and we need to do a lot of
storage engine level tuning I'll give an
example of that and so yeah so I think
it we felt and in fact like the HBase
back in the Dell talk about is pretty
simple shouldnt was really good engineer
but yeah he built this in a month so the
HBase back in for it so it will take
that much effort and obviously over time
we have added a lot of work to it but
yeah hope that answers your question
yeah so yeah so neo4j I think we didn't
do a performance test specifically we
did do some load tests initially to make
sure that HBase would work for us we are
now building the mysql back end and we
are doing some lotus there as well we
obviously compared with existing systems
that we have key value storage systems
on top of which people have built
products hunt and we also use Redis and
yeah so we looked at a few different
options with load tests and HBase was
already running at pretty large scale
and at Pinterest so it was sort of a
natural first choice that's why we
picked it yeah
okay so the question is how is a cluster
defined yeah cluster is sort of a a
group of nerds sort of a 1h base back
end with some stateless thrift server
machines in front of it that's sort of
logically distinct from another HBase
cluster so it's kind of like clusters in
the storage system level and the Zen
aspect of it is just sort of a thrift
service or some service like a Java
service in fact in our case running on
top of HBase so it's just sort of
isolation in terms of machines and yeah
so the yeah I can answer your question
yes so the clusters don't talk to each
other obviously applications are
sometimes built to talk to multiple Zen
clusters depending on what they are
doing but yeah so a Zen cluster is
self-contained cool so yeah so let me go
into a little bit of the internals of
them so yeah I think we covered this a
bit so we built a hitch pins back end we
working under my SQL backend how many
people are familiar with the HBase data
model okay a few people so I will just
quickly go with the data model because
that will put the other part of the talk
in the context so I mean essentially
HBase is modeled on Google's big table I
think what they call a a large salted
distributed sparse hash map and
essentially you have rows and columns
columns are contained within groups
called column families for example data
is a column family here it has a couple
of columns and we have one row with a
couple of values here's another row with
the third column you can add these
columns sort of on demand
at will not every cell needs to be
populated that's where the sparse aspect
comes from yeah so that's that's all
it's it's pretty simple sort of key
value with the notion of columns and
column families so given that sort of
okay let's look at each part of Zen and
very quickly look at how we would model
the Zen data on top of HBase so the
first thing is properties so some
properties are built in like say score
four edges or type for both edges and
nodes and then you can have your own
custom properties like name and distance
in this case so the way this is stored
is yeah so each property is a column in
HBase and the row is either a node ID or
an edge reference an edge reference
being from node ID type to node ID so
that uniquely identifies an edge so I
think this answers the question around
like the sizes of row keys is usually
pretty small because it's totally in our
control and column names are the
property names and the value in the cell
is the value of the property so that's
sort of a very simple way of modeling
properties and then the property index
so as I mentioned earlier so is the
unique and the non unique index so the
way the unique index works is it's a row
that contains the node or edge type the
property name and the property value so
that you have there
10 name equals Ben Smith so that's the
thing that you have an index on and for
the unique index the the node ID is
inside the cell and you use a cash
operation when you create it and this
ensures that it's unique right so that's
how the unique index works with a
non-unique index it's very similar but
you actually put the ID in as part of
the row key and the cell itself is empty
and this way you can do a scan and
retrieve all the node IDs that are part
of that index does that make sense so
and the one other thing is you have a
hash of the sort of everything except
the ID part of the row key now we take a
hash and prepend it to the key the
reason to do that is basically to get
some of some kind of balance so balanced
sort of indexes across
hbase.regionserver.blockcachesize I'm
sure a lot of you done things I've
anything so the edge score index which
retrieves edges from a node is very
similar except that there's a score
component there which is highlighted in
yellow and the score gives you the
ordering and the same sort of
intentionally before the node ID there
to give you that ordering so pretty
simple and count again yeah so given a
node ID an edge direction and the type B
store account so again it's pretty
simple so it's a pretty simple data
model I think this covers the basics of
it and as I said like I think we were
able to build this in about a month and
of course took a while to get the
production performance and so on out of
it so now I'll talk about a little bit
about some of the things that we have to
do over the last year as
as we has more products came and built
on top of zen and some of the new
features we need to add and performance
during that we needed to do it so you
had a question ya know I so I think yeah
so this the edge score index is usually
small so it's all the edges that are
associated with a particular node so
those could go in the millions in the
rare cases but yeah it's not going to go
into tens of millions or something like
that so yeah we don't use the hash for
the edges core index whereas yeah so oh
oh over here oh yeah so the question is
I think if you have a hash prefix how do
you how are you able to scan and so the
hash prefix is only on this part of the
low key so not on the last part which is
a variable part so essentially for a
given property name and value for a
particular value so in this case like
lastname equals Smith you will be in the
same region and all the node ID is
associated with that index so yeah and a
particular property value is all in one
place but different property values are
in different regions so that's how it
works yes
yeah so I think it's an ascending order
of that the score or whatever is on the
right side there in this case it's a
node ID we actually added a feature
later to do descending scores as well
but yeah the thing you cannot do in
HBase is that you cannot scan in the
other direction you can only scan in one
direction yes so the question is can you
ask how many nodes are pointing at this
node yes so we materialize these indexes
are built in both sides of the edge for
incoming and outgoing and in fact I
think if you see the edge score index it
says out and in there so that basically
means an outgoing edge or an incoming
edge yes any other questions on the data
model cool so yeah in terms of new
features that we needed to add this one
is basically something I mean is a soft
delete is probably obvious tension is
your database but the idea was like
people wanted to be able to delete nodes
but keep the relationships so that in
case you need to undelete for a good
example of that is a few store user
objects inside them and sometimes you
deactivate users for like either the
user deactivates themselves or like
because for spam or something like that
but you need to be able to reactivate if
you if you want and then you are able to
reactivate and retrieve all the edge
relationships that you had so this one
is a little bit interesting also we
found for performance reasons clients
used to sometimes retrieve data from zen
and then cash it in memcache or
somewhere else we said we lied a cache
so actually an intern project last
summer we lied a cash-in sides n which
gives you basically we're able to say
what performance do you need will get it
for you with some combination of cash
and a back
database rather than the client having
to do caching on their own so this is
something that we found useful we added
a feature called namespaces kind of
gives you the ability to partition
certain data sets that are not related
in two different HBase tables the goal
there is essentially you can move from
one cluster to another if we need to we
can do tuning for a use case specific
case like silence up like that save the
data in ames case one needs to be tuned
at the storage engine in a different way
from the one in ames phase two variable
to do things like that and a number of
other smaller features things like
online type schema change making some of
the features optional not everyone
needed adjustment alleged in both
directions so if you don't want to pay
for if you don't need it you don't need
to pay for it you can make it you can
remote edge counts if you don't want to
do it you don't need to pay for it the
tree will have sub set of properties
like I wanna rather than all properties
things like that so descending it's code
for convenience and I will talk a little
bit quickly but some of the performance
challenges that we had and how we try to
solve it this particular I think was for
the smart feed home feed workload so the
home feed basically is a system which is
sort of push based on feed like whenever
someone creates a pin we found out that
pin to all the people that follow that
pinner pinner is the user of interest so
this is a very very demanding workload
with doing 1,000,000 edge in search per
second and so on so what I think what we
found when we first put this workload on
top of Zen is that the bottle like was
kind of each log flushes so each time
you do a right into HBase it has to do a
update a right ahead log which is an
HDFS so that became a bottleneck in
performance so the way we solve that is
pretty simple like I mean how pretty
obvious this is using
matching one approach to batching was on
the client side you insert edges in bulk
rather than one at a time but you also
have the ability to do matching on the
xenserver itself which is this notion of
sort of group commit you buffer edits
for a while and then commit them
together and acknowledge back together
so this reduced h log plushies by orders
of magnitude and got this workload
working out for us on top of them then
there are tricks around memory and
performance within the HBase storage
model so each base uses bloom filters to
reduce this seeks but there are cases
when you don't need a bloom filter so if
you're not doing random lookups you
don't need a bloom filter and we were
able to save memory for other users by
actually removing the bloom filter
salloum filter is meant to be sort of a
small data structure but in fact in
HBase the cost is one byte per row which
is non-trivial it can be pretty large so
if you don't need it you can disable the
bloom filter gives you more memory for
the block cash for HBase so a little bit
of details in terms of HBase tuning of
block sizes tweaking the encoding and
compression so I think by default HBase
as fast if encoding and snappy
compression but for certain super high
right heavy workloads we found that this
was very CPU expensive in terms when you
are doing compaction and major
compaction so we sort of disabled
compression and used prefix encoding and
that that work better things like that
so a lot of small things going in deeper
into the HBase storage engine and the
reason as I mentioned earlier we were
able to do this is because of namespaces
and cluster isolation so we could
isolate certain use cases and tune the
hell out of those when we need to so the
last thing I want to talk about is data
consistency I'm sure some of you
wondered when I talked about the data
model what about data consistency so
when you add an edge into them there are
all these operations that need to happen
so you need to create the indexers you
need to
had the properties add those core
indexes in both directions materialized
counts all of these are separate HBase
operations so that question was how do
you get consistency and when I mean when
I mean consistency I don't mean in the
database level obviously HBase itself is
strongly consistent across replicas but
it's really consistency between all
these different tables and the core data
in the indexes so the question was if
you want strong consistency we could do
it through some sort of a distributed
transaction and I think their
implementations out there on top of
HBase to do dispute transactions but
obviously they come with a huge
performance cost and that wouldn't work
for us at our scale so what we did is
essentially offer sort of a relaxed
consistency model I think similar to
what Facebook does for similar systems
that they have basically our
applications can tolerate some small
level of inconsistency like so for
example if you if the count is off by
one son into the world for most of our
use cases so we were able to focus on
performance yet we did our best to
reduce consistencies inconsistencies and
tackle them so things like when you do
this sequence of operations and
something fails we do manual roll back
in the xenserver so tricks like that
help you reduce some of the
inconsistencies but not completely get
rid of them so that we have offline jobs
which we call doctors n in this case to
periodically scan the whole cluster and
fix inconsistencies and we also told to
do one of inconsistency fixes so some of
the future work here so we are
continuing titrate on doctors n we are
as I mentioned earlier adding other
backends we want to look into doing
distributed transactions for use cases
that need strong consistency and are
willing to pay for it with performance
and finally later this year we want to
open source then so it's kind of like
there's a good point in the life cycle
where you can think of open sourcing and
at this point then is pretty mature but
you are still light rating on it in
in a few months I think it'll be a right
time to open source it so we really hope
to do that and yeah that's it thanks a
lot and I'm happy to take any other
questions yes yeah so the question is
how are you generating globally unique
64-bit ID so we actually have an ID
generation service that uses there's
this thing that Twitter open sourced
call for the snowflake yes so we have
something like snowflake but we didn't
use snowflake itself because we needed
these IDs to be distinct from IDs from
another system that we have but
essentially like snowflake we have a
snowflake like service yeah
yeppers
sure yeah so the question is when we I
treat quickly at what point would you
decide to cut a certain project or a
feature so that's a very good question
and I think we are sort of trying to
figure that out like I don't think we
have a yes this is the way we do it it
kind of varies from project to project
but pinterest tends to be usually very
data-driven so we typically try to build
something quickly and people things like
Zen allow you to do that but also in
some cases you hack together some
solution and launch a product as sort of
a small experiment and then if you see
the data that it's working out well and
it seems to be adopted well then you
usually end up building more robust
infrastructure and sort of building it
in at larger scale or you give up so I
think yeah it's it's more an art the
science i think there's no exact formula
but usually data tells you very quickly
whether it's working or not and of
course there's a piece of hydrating as
well like so sometimes it doesn't work
in the first iteration then you i'd rate
a little bit but at some point you
decide let's cut this and one yeah yeah
yes so the question is are there a few
large HBase tables or multiple tables so
we are literally the tables that I
showed there in that namespace slide are
all there are likelier so they're like
three or four tables / yeah so yeah then
uses a very small number of tables
something like this are maybe like one
more table where that's at yes a very
small number of tables / namespace any
other questions yes yeah so the question
is are did we look into using some kind
of optimized HBase from a bar or no so
we are right now using a stock sort of
HBase in open source we have a number of
patches and so on is actually a talk I
think on YouTube by one of our engineers
about how we go at HBase working in an
online sort of user-facing way like I
think as many of you know HBase largely
has been used in analytics and sort of
offline world outside of sort of a few
companies so things like mean time to
recovery so there's a bunch of work that
we put into HBase that we also want to
open source at some point in order to
get it working for online sort of user
facing work work work load so yeah so
yeah we haven't tried and you'll be
optimized H business HP is really nice I
guess
yes yeah
good yeah so the question is how did you
design a cash for this kind of data set
that's a very good question so the first
version of the cash that our intern
built with excellent above read is so
red is actually offers you some data
structures that make it more convenient
to things like edge lists so obviously
the properties of them are just key
value so you can catch those pretty
easily that was the first thing that
people wanted to cash counts are also
very easy to cash and in terms of
negative queries edge base is already
good with it so really the challenge is
in cashing edge lists and you can do
that in memcache and in fact we ended up
moving from Redis to memcache for other
reasons more recently but yes the
original implementation was using a
Redis sorted set which made it very easy
to do edgeless but we do have the
ability of list based caches and mm
catchment yes they are a little less
efficient and convenient to use
cool yeah thanks a lot